hi Simon it's a great pleasure and it's
a honor actually to us to be able to
have you today at Swiss Army leadership
talks um good morning actually I think
what time is it on your side it's uh
quarter past 10 in the morning okay good
morning hope you had your first coffee
already I I've had already had about 12
cups yes no I'm good to go thank you
very very much it's nice to be here here
actually was at 700 p.m. in the evening
so welcome to Swiss Army leadership
talks my family it's a great pleasure
and a great honor to have you my first
question would be actually why did you
accept our
invitation um well I do a lot of work
with the the US Military and over the
years of having a relationship with them
I have a real love for those who put on
the uniform of their Nation um I think
uh I I know in Switzerland uh everybody
does um and not so in the US um and I
think there's a there's a I think you
learn a skill
um in military service that you you
would otherwise not learn or learn not
as easily which is the the skill of
teamwork and the scheme this the skill
of service and taking care of each other
and recognizing that difficult
situations are are more easily overcome
when you work together and you know ours
is a world of of of of personal ambition
and I think military service uh teaches
us um um uh sort of joint ambition and
so when you when you offer the
invitation it was it was an honor to
accept thank you very much again I've
read most of your books and one of my
favorite is why eaters leaders eat less
and that's exactly about armed forces
and leadership in Armed Forces you
already started explaining a bit what
makes leadership in Armed Forces
different but then what do you think
about comradery and what is like what
makes leadership really different in
Armed Forces so like from a people
perspective so I'll tell you a story
from the United States Marine Corps um I
had an opportunity to visit OCS in
quanico Virginia and the colonel in
charge of OCS um was supposed to give me
a briefing on what they do at OCS and
how they train their officers Etc and he
showed up late and I and I know you know
this but Marines don't show up late ever
um um and he walked into the room and
apologized and said I'm sorry we've had
an incident on bass so of course I was
curious I said what happened what
happened you know he said well it's
serious enough that you know we're
considering throwing one of our Marines
out of OCS throwing one of our Marines
out of the Marine Corps so I'm thinking
oh my God what what crime did this
person commit I said what' he do he said
he fell asleep on Watch and I said
that's it like he fell asleep on watch
in the woods of Virginia and you're
going to throw him out of the Marine
Corps for that that's a bit harsh don't
you think and he said no you don't
understand when we asked him about it he
denied it when we asked him about it
again he denied it again and only when
we showed him irrefutable proof did he
say quote I want to take responsibility
for my actions he said the problem we
have is you don't take responsibility
for your actions at the time you get
caught you take responsibility for your
actions at the time you perform your
actions he said we have another Marine
that fell asleep he admitted it we we
punished him but we have no problem with
him and then the colonel went on to
explain he says you have to understand
if I put this kid in a leadership
position in a combat situation and his
Marines think for one minute that he's
trying to protect himself at the expense
of others if he's trying to just Advance
his own career trust will decline trust
will break and people will
die and so I started to understand that
what it means to lead what camaraderie
means in these environments is that is
literally Our Lives depend on each other
and I don't have to like you but I do
have to trust you and I think that in in
the in the civilian world we confuse
those two that I only trust you when I
like you and if I don't like you I don't
trust you and in and in this case it's
about responsibility to the service not
responsibility to someone's
personality um and when someone is a
good actor when someone has honor and
this is one of the things that I lament
which is the word honor doesn't really
have usage in the civilian world like we
don't use that word that she's honorable
he's honorable um but in the military
that word still has meaning and you
describe someone as I don't like him but
he's absolutely honorable
um and and that is the basis for for
camaraderie I don't think you can have
true camaraderie unless you have the
belief that someone is watching your
back camaraderie actually is another
term that is only used in military
environments so in civilian life we
don't use that very often I think that
story was very impressive about trust
and Leadership has a lot to do with
trust so here right now in in Burn we
have many leaders we have leaders like
out of police Armed Forces but also the
economy so how do you think Army like
military leadership can be translated
into like civilian leadership do you see
there a bridge or something in
common absolutely um for one I think
that the military is very good at
understanding the difference between the
battle and the war um which is uh which
is you can you fight to win battles but
you can lose battles and still win the
war um and you and I think military
understands the short game and the long
game a lot a lot better which is when
you go into action you play to win but
when you're not in action you play to
improve and so you're the military is in
a constant state of constant Improvement
how do we make our systems better how do
we make our training better how do we
make our leaders better how do we make
everything's constant Improvement fight
to win then go back to constant
Improvement and I think in the civilian
World everybody's just trying to win all
the time and they forget they forget the
long game and the problem is when we
only play the short game when we only
play to win or Advance our careers or
look like Heroes we actually do
long-term damage to an organization
that's the opposite of constant
Improvement and so I think the ability
to understand when you're playing a
finite game and when you're playing an
infinite game the military is much
better at that um uh I think in the
civilian World especially it's a lot of
putting out fires without consideration
of of of the greater of the greater
picture now we speak a lot actually
about lead leip and we learn about
leadership and we all read your books
but what what I hear very often from
actually from Young leaders they have
high pressure on them because they want
to be great leaders and as they see that
cannot
fulfills this this um pressure or the
pressure they under or their own
impression of how they should be as
Leaders they actually break under that
pressure what would you tell
them most importantly nobody nobody is
smart enough or strong strong enough to
do this thing called leadership all by
themselves leadership is just too
difficult um and the great leaders I
know they know how to ask for help they
know how to lean on someone when they
are struggling they know how to say um
um I don't understand um and so I think
number one is there's no such thing as a
great leader without a team of great
people around them um uh leadership is a
team sport um uh and and thinking you
have to do everything alone
uh you're going to burn yourself out and
you're going to break yourself and
ultimately you'll hurt the organization
and so so so ask for help when you need
it admit you don't know things when you
don't know them um and uh and you find
you're surrounded by people who want to
help
you and that leads to another question
actually are great leaders are they born
or are they being like made or can they
learn it themselves yeah so it's it's
it's an age-old question with a simple
answer which is Le leaders are made um
uh there's no there's no leadership
Gene um and if you look at all of the
people that we would consider great
leaders you can see that they had a
journey you know uh they all had
Journeys Gandhi started off as a as a a
lawyer who who failed the bar in the in
the UK and moved to South Africa where
he was more likely to pass the bar I
mean and then he saw the Injustice in
South Africa what if he passed the bar
in the UK there would be no Gandhi you
know they all went on Journeys and they
all had trials and tribulations that
taught them the skill of leadership
leadership is a is a learnable practice
skill and like any skill like riding a
bicycle um if you if you do it a lot you
get good at it and if you don't do it a
lot your muscles will atrophy um there's
there's no such thing as an expert in
leadership um every great leader I've
ever met considers themselves a student
of leadership they're constantly reading
books about it watching talks about it
uh having conversations about it
regardless of how much they've
accomplished in their careers so um
every great leader that any of us have
ever known or followed or admired I can
guarantee you they went on their own
Journey um so yeah leadership is a is a
learnable practical skill so you said
that you learn leadership out of
actually of experience experience you
make but then is it like is it necessary
to have a coach or a mentor to to learn
leadership to give like feedback and and
guide you through to become a better
leader I think that's a leading question
uh the the answer is of course
I mean you can't be a great athlete
without a coach uh you know you don't
have you don't have the same objectivity
and perspective on yourself as someone
looking from the outside in um so I
absolutely do believe in mentors and
coaches um the most important thing that
I have found in a mentor relationship is
that there's a difference between a
mentor and a champion and sometimes I
think we get those things confused a
champion is someone who can help your
career put in a good word for you you
know uh where a mentor usually is
outside side of your chain of command um
a good Mentor that they have no ability
to help Advance your career the only
thing they can do is be 100% objective
and tell you what they think based on
how you're acting or what you're doing
um uh uh and I think those relationships
are imentally valuable because we can't
say to them put in a good word for me
they have no ability um nor do they feel
that responsibility quite frankly so
they have the ability to be totally
totally objective they're outside the
chain now you can have a good Mentor
inside the chain of but the problem is
it's complicated by the chain of command
um so I think good mentors are outside
and sometimes even outside the industry
um outside of your unit you know outside
of your your your your MOS whatever it
is um uh because then they don't really
know your job they only know
you but as a leader I don't want to
create followers I want to create other
leaders so that means that I'm always
also a coach or a mentor as a leader but
then what makes a good Mentor then or a
coach what do I have to do become a
better
Coach um
so I think coaching is not about telling
people what to do it's about helping
them see things that they may not see
but ultimately people are responsible
for their own actions and I I've learned
in my own Journey when I've offered
coaching to people that when I give them
an observation or maybe offer some
points of view if they fight with me or
get defensive I I would fight back and
say no you're wrong you're missing it
and it would became about me being
accountable and so if they don't
understand something that's different uh
but when they're defensive now if they
push back I go I'm just telling you what
I think you can absolutely ignore me you
can throw it out I'm I'm just here to
help but I'm not here to tell you what
to do I'm not I'm not right I don't have
answers it's just a point of view it's
just an
observation this is your career this is
this is your leadership you do what you
think is right and the minute you push
the accountability on the person that
they're responsible for their own
actions all of a sudden they're much
more open to to coaching and I like to
remind coaches that if you go watch
football for example the coach is not
allowed to run onto the field to play
you know um even if the coach knows what
to do even if the coach knows how to do
it better the coach is not allowed to
play in the game and it's the same for
coaching and Leadership which is the
coach is not allowed to make the
decision the coach is not allowed to
rush in to to lead the group The Coach
can only stand on the sidelines and
offer what they think is help to the
players But ultimately the players
responsible for their own behavior and
their own
decisions interesting question about
responsibility of a leader and I very
much agree sometimes Leia think it's
them to make all the decisions Define
all the plans and I agree it's not it's
definitely not Simon I know that your
you dream of a world where everyone
actually a working world where everyone
is very enthusiastic very much motivated
and I would say I share that dream but
and also I what do we have to do in
Swiss armed forces that everyone is
every day motivated and enthusiastic how
do we create such an environment well I
don't think that's true um I don't think
anyone I don't think we can create an
organization where everyone every day is
motivated and enthusiastic um that's
like we love our children every day but
we don't like our children every day you
know it's like we can love our work
every day we don't have to like it every
day um we can be inspired at work every
day we don't have to be motivated at
work every day you know there are other
things that are factors in our lives and
so I think the most important thing is
that it is a team because no team is
operating with every player at the
highest level every moment of every day
it sort of goes like this you know it's
like any kind of relationship um where
we when if if one person is is
struggling for whatever reason that the
other players can come in to to hold
them up and and and help compensate for
any work that needs to get done and and
it and you lean on each other and that's
what makes it Flawless it's the fluidity
of being able to lean on each other and
the relationships are so good and we
start to understand each other that we
know when I can stand in we also know
each other's strengths and weaknesses so
we know who to plug in because
somebody's better at this this has
happened to me where even just as a
leader my personality I'm not getting
through to somebody on my team they're
just not listening to me but it's my
personality and so instead of me just
doing the same thing over and over again
I'll ask somebody else to fill in
because their personality might work a
lot better and it works a lot of the
times um so I think it's that ability to
understand that this is a team this is a
team this is a team at all times it is a
team that keeps the inspiration and the
desire to come to work really
high and I said in the beginning we
understand it's one of your dreams but
then tell us the truth how many
companies have you seen including armed
forces that really fulfill already that
dream well it's an ideal right I imagine
a world in which the vast majority of
people wake up inspired feel safe
wherever they are are and end the day
fulfilled by the work that they do it is
an ideal I know that we will never get
there but we will die trying that's the
point and so I have met um many units
within the military and many units that
have failed um uh uh uh where they are
more advanced towards that Vision than
others the same in in in the corporate
world there are some companies that are
way way more advanced in that Vision
than others and I think what's most
important is the constant striving um we
we we talked before about understanding
the infinite game by understanding the
the the idea of constant Improvement and
the ones that are making the greatest
headways it's not that they get
everything right and make every right
decision they absolutely do not it's how
they deal with uh when they make bad
decisions or how they deal with it when
they get pushed back on their heels um
and the idea of constantly improving and
and accepting that this is a moment in
time now let's move forwards um th those
are the ones that I
admire I like very much the concept of
constant improving this as you have said
before it's also in the armed forces
we're very much used to that so we do
what we what is called an after action
review but that should be also on the
personal level then not just on the
action itself on the mission but also on
the personal
level one of the things that I think
works very well in the military that I
think the private sector could learn
from is the military does the after
action review and and nobody's sometimes
the feedback is Harsh um uh you know
it's very honest somebody's screwed up
you're going to get told that you
screwed up but even if your ego is a
little damaged the reason it works is
because everybody understands that we're
doing this so that we can be better so
that the organization can be better so
that that we're more likely to succeed
in the future whereas I think in the
private sector we're so worried about
someone's ego or hurting someone's
feelings and by the way I do not believe
that Honesty has to be brutal you know
we talk about brutal honesty honesty
does not have to be brutal it just has
to be honest you know you don't have to
say you screwed up but I I know that you
can do better than you did today day
that's an honest assessment without
being brutal um uh but the point is I
think that in the in the private sector
we can do a lot a lot better at that
I'll tell you a funny story so like when
I go to a military briefing versus when
I go to a corporate presentation right
at the end of a military briefing very
often the the briefer will say Spears
Spears in other words right at the end
of The Briefing tell me what's wrong
tell me where I screwed up tell me what
can be better where are the holes in my
logic tell me where I can improve we're
in the private sector we give a
presentation and we go pretty good
pretty good right tell show me tell me
the places that we're good tell me the
places that you really like right um and
we get defensive when people poke holes
and again I think the military better
understands the idea of constant
Improvement which means having thick
skin and being open to criticism and
I've learned that I've learned that in
my own work I crave the criticism now
people like oh that was good that was
great I'm like no no no tell tell me
what can be better I've learned to
really
enjoy the the that negative feedback
because it means I can be better and
it's delivered from people who aren't
trying to hurt me it's delivered from
people who are trying to help me make my
work
better um so so I think that private
sector can really learn that from the
military and now let's turn it around so
what can the military learn about from
the private sector then so um one of the
advantages that private SE private
sector has is they have a less strict uh
um formal hierarchy so in the military
you know you have to work X many years
to make each Rank and you know it's
relatively organized by age if you're
older you're probably more senior if
you're younger you're probably more
Junior and that's pretty much how it is
whereas in the private sector if you're
truly a talent and truly a go-getter you
can sometimes lead people who are older
than you you can sometimes lead people
who have been in the OR organization or
in the industry longer than you um and
uh that's a huge advantage and I think
we're not asking the military to upset
the traditional hierarchy I understand
why it works but I think inviting the
smart people to sit at the table um
makes a makes a makes a big difference
I'll give you a real life example it
just happens to be another Marine
example I was visiting Camp Pendleton
and there was a young Marine Captain a
Raider Special Forces
uh uh uh who was in charge of looking
after me and he was a history major in
University and we just got to talking
while we're in the car and he told me
about an experience he had in Iraq where
he was tasked with uh training and
equipping a group of Iraqi soldiers
which is really exciting for a young for
a young officer and so first let's get
everybody a rifle great done everybody's
got a rifle he says okay now let's get
everybody a ruck sack and his Iraqi
counter part said sorry there's no Rock
sacks on base and the Marine said no
problem whoever does your procurement uh
your requisitions get get some rcks and
the Iraqi counterpart said no no you
don't understand those no Ruck sacks in
Iraq anywhere in the
country and so this young officer said
well where do you put your water then
and the guy said you put it in your
pockets or on the back of the truck he
goes okay let's say the truck's disabled
and you run out of water in your pockets
then what happens and the guy says you
die and then this young Captain
remembered his history that in the west
our the way we fight our militaries are
largely based on Roman theories of
fighting which is long supply lines to
supply the forward operating forces
whereas the Arabs are Raiders they don't
have supply lines they leave in the
morning with a day's worth of uh uh
material and you fight and if you win
then you eat the other guy's stuff and
drink his water or if you lose you come
home and so here we are in the West
trying to undo thousands of years of
raider history and turn them into Roman
Legions of course it wasn't
working and that's because the planners
who weren't at the front lines had no
idea that this was even happening and so
my question is I'm not saying make this
young Captain a colonel but maybe invite
the young Captain to sit at the table to
advise the
colonels um and I think the military can
do a better job if you go to your
company grade commanders or or above and
say who are your smartest people they
know who they are snag those people and
let them sit in meetings and advise
because I think that they would offer a
point of view that is otherwise
missing great story I like that one but
then also coming back to you mentioned
the ranks we have in in Armed Forces
like you mentioned Colonels or captains
or or soldiers or or ncos and then what
I experience very often is um Soldier
levels are scared to give feedback to
like senior like Majors or Colonels how
how did you experience how how can it be
overcome so to to for soldiers to to
have the courage to give feedback also
to more senior levels because also their
like their promotion might depend on the
relationship they have and that might
also be the same might be true also for
the economy so giving feedback always
might give me a bad situation to get
promoted later so that goes to the
quality of the leader quite frankly
which is um a leader who recognizes and
rewards feedback is going to encourage
more feedback so if I ask for feedback
and say I'm open to it and then somebody
gives it to me and I either defend
myself criticize them or or reject it
then I'm creating an environment in
which no one's going to give me feedback
or at least they won't give me h
feedback they're just going to tell me
how great I am um whereas if somebody
gives me negative feedback I don't have
to listen to it I don't have to agree
with it but if I can encourage it I go
thank you tell me more go on yes thank
you oh this is really helpful thank you
so the leader will create the conditions
and if people can see that happen if
they see a a young officer you know and
you by the way there's there's a
difference between respectful and
disrespectful feedback you know and to
maintain a spr of core and and and and
and maintain the rank structure it can
be done respectfully sir can I give you
some feedback yes you can or can we do
it later or let's do it in my office
right as opposed to hey let me tell you
what I think that's disrespectful
because you're not evaluating the
situation that that maybe that officer
that more senior officer or NCO has in
mind so may I give you some feedback
asking permission is how it starts may I
give you some feedback and if they say
no okay then I know my place right but a
good a good leader a good NCO or a good
officer uh or even a good good uh uh
Soldier uh because because feedback can
go this way as well um uh will will will
want to receive it and create conditions
in which it's in which it's welcomed and
that then it'll get encouraged and then
what you're doing is you're creating a
culture of feedback in which it can go
up and down very very easily um you can
also create some formalized systems
where it happens but the informal ones
work as well I like the second part of
your answer actually also for like every
Soldier or every employee has the possib
to ask to provide some feedback sure
that's a that's a good and ask for it
like I said before you know can you give
me some feedback of how I can improve oh
you're great well that's not true
there's always room for improvement can
you please tell me that I want that and
again if the leader asks for it instead
of just waiting to be to be given it the
leader says I like some feedback how I
can do better um you know and you create
a form for it in this meeting we're
going to talk about what we as an
organization can do better or how I can
do better as a leader so I want all of
your answers and I've done this with my
organization where when you have those
sessions um even if you agree or
disagree even if the leaders are
triggered you basically you're in
receiving mode go on tell me more and if
you don't understand you can ask
followup questions but please tell me
more go on yes and it's it's just taking
it all in right then the next day when
people have emptied their buckets then
you can say okay yesterday we talked
about what we can do better and what I
can do better now I want to talk about
where we can do better and what you
think you can do that we can improve
this and now it's all positivity and
moving forward because I've had the
opportunity in the Forum to get all the
junk out ready so to separate those two
I think it's very important to separate
the emptying of the bucket and the and
the looking forwards because you can't
do it in the same meeting it's too
there's too much emotion um uh uh but a
leader that welcomes it and asks for it
and creates form for it it creates an
environment for
it going back to one of your books
always start with why so in arm fores we
used to give orders to each other so why
how can the why be transported in an
order so how can it give orders that
include the why the purpose of the
mission so why is very simply context
and I think when we give people context
um they better understand the orders
they are being given right so for
example um move this wall move this
frence from here to
there and then they'll do it I mean they
understand how the the rank structure
works but they may not be inspired and
motivated they may not feel like they're
contributing to anything and so simply
offering context right simp simply by
saying um we understand that by having
this fence here we actually limit the
distance that we can for our our our our
our trucks to get through um it's making
more difficult for them and we can only
get one at a time um so what I want you
guys to do is move it over there because
we need room to get more more things
through simultaneously so we can move
quicker so move this from here to
there um and so you're still giving the
same order but by providing the context
you're allowing for them to now be
Innovative because if all they were do
told was move here from there then
there're then what happens if there's a
big boulder you know they they don't
know the reason they were moving it we
here you asking them to solve problems
which includes moving the fence and so
you'll find much more Ingenuity if
they're in if they're in the loop
basically if they understand the context
so I think that's That's essential when
when giving orders and and look you know
better than I do that and I think this
is very important that the private
sector does not understand but it's very
very important to understand the private
sector thinks military is all command
and control right do this do as I tell
you take an order and so they think that
being a strong leader because they've
seen too many movies is barking orders
and telling people what to do now you
know as well as I do that that that that
is a part of leadership
um where you I'm going to tell you a
task without any context and you're
going to do it but that is reserved for
moments of
chaos and when there isn't chaos you're
spending time building trust you're
spending time offering context you're
spending time building this breed of
core so that when you are in a chaotic
situation you absolutely can bark orders
and scream and yell because I don't have
time for feedback and I don't have time
to give you context and they will follow
the orders with high motivation because
they trust they trust that you would not
give them an order that would needlessly
put them at danger even though they
understand that you'll sometimes make
mistakes and so I think in business in
private sector we need to learn to
adjust as well which is command and
control works fine in short periods of
time and moments of chaos but it cannot
be nobody has the energy to endure that
on a daily
basis I see and what you're saying is
actually do have to establish their
relationship first and if there is a
relationship of trust a trust
relationship you can also bark orders or
give orders and sometimes this is
necessary like in in Armed Forces but
also in aviation or in other
environments sometimes yeah might be
necessary but it's it's earned it's
earned okay I I experienced it during I
experienced it during covid when covid
hit and we went into lockdown my company
was going to go bankrupt I mean all of
our income came from inperson things we
weren't going to survive and I remember
I had a meeting with my team and we're a
very sort of lovey lovey Kumbaya you
know and I said I care about your
feelings if some if I say something that
upsets you I want to know but I don't
want to know now tell me in two weeks I
said because right now we have we have
we're in survival mode and I don't have
time or energy to deal with all the
frilly stuff I care but we're going to
do it later and it would worked fine and
I went into command control because we
had to it was a time of extreme stress
and it worked just fine because we'd
spent years building the
trust so Simon we have like 300 young
leaders ncos young Business Leaders in
this room now what kind of advice would
you give them for young leaders to
become like more senior and grow as
Leaders like a final message to our
audience here I I think it goes back to
what I said before which is the most
important lesson I learned as a young
leader was I don't have to know all the
answers and I don't have to pretend that
I do and the biggest biggest skill that
I learned that profoundly changed the
course of my career as I learn to ask
for help and it is amazing that when you
learn to ask for help with confidence
not I can't do this and can you help me
but I'm like hey I have no clue what I'm
doing can somebody please help me what
I'm doing here do you know how to do
this because I'm an idiot you know if
you can learn to ask for help with
confidence you will it will have more
impact on your growth as a leader and
your growth in your career career than
almost anything else being the smartest
in the room is not important being the
one who's willing to ask for help is the
most
important that was a great final
statement Simon so thank you very much
it was a real honor it was a real
pleasure talking to you I think it was
just amazing and there is a lot of
admiration for you also in Switzerland
as in many of our of of our participants
audience here read all your books and if
not they would actually start to I'm
quite sure so thank you very much for
for spending time with us thank you very
much for accepting the invitation it was
just great thank you very much Simon
thanks so much for helping me uh thanks
so much for inviting me I really
appreciate it um take care of yourself
and take care of each other thank you
and you too
byebye